merci monsieur le foll la parole est un
monsieur georges fenech merci monsieur
le président mes chers collègues la
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur la commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur les attentats 2015 que
j'ai conduite avec notre collègue
sébastien pietrasanta a formulé à la
quasi-unanimité 40 propositions dont à
mes yeux la principale est la refonte
complète de l'organisation de nos
services de renseignement chargés de
déjouer les attentats or que ce soit
vous ou votre prédécesseur
vous êtes resté totalement opposés à
cette nécessité pourtant absolue dois je
vous rappeler que les patrons de la dgs
y ait de la dgse ont honnêtement reconnu
devant notre commission que les
attentats de janvier de 9 en 2015 était
bien un échec de leur service dès lors
je m'interroge sur les raisons de ce
manque de volonté politique à l'instar
d'ailleurs de deux journalistes qui
publient aujourd'hui même un ouvrage
intitulé où sont passés nos espions et
dans lequel dénonce le déni du
gouvernement sur les failles de nos
renseignements
malgré tout vous persistez puisque dans
le cadre d'une mission de suivi de nos
préconisations
vous venez une nouvelle fois est
clairement de nous faire connaître votre
refus de renforcer la coordination de
nos différents services en rejetant
d'emblée la création plus haut niveau de
l'état d'une agence nationale de lutte
antiterroriste déjà qualifiée avec un
certain dédain je dois le dire par votre
prédécesseur de plum pudding pouvez vous
monsieur le ministre
pour vous il ne faudrait toucher à rien
je vous cite le poids des enjeux liés à
la lutte anti-terroriste n'autorise pas
envisager de supprimer ce qui fonctionne
bien en la matière écrivez vous comment
osez vous prétendre un bon
fonctionnement de nos services quand
depuis janvier 2015 230 victimes sont
tombées sous les balles des terroristes
islamistes pourtant identifié et qui ont
pu passer à l'acte faudra-t-il donc
monsieur le ministre se résoudre à
attendre l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
majorité pour qu'une telle réforme
retenu notamment par le candidat
françois fillon soit enfin mise en
oeuvre
l'apport l'état monsieur bruno le roux
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
député félin qu il est vrai que vous
avez avec sébastien pietrasanta a rendu
un rapport avec un certain nombre de
propositions de procédure un certain
nombre de propositions de gestion de ces
moments de crise très particuliers que
sont les actes terroristes qui appelle
forcément la réflexion vous faites des
propositions en matière d'organisation
et de réorganisation dont je vous
confirme les termes qui vous avait été
donné par monsieur le premier ministre
le 11 juillet dernier dans une lettre
très détaillé qui disait la façon dont
nous entendons aujourd'hui donner des
moyens supplémentaires à nos services de
renseignement je ne vais pas vous
refaire vous le connaissez mais il est
utile de dire que le service de
renseignement sont organisés et
d'ailleurs au moment où je vous parle
puisque vous parlez des victimes et nous
avons toute une pensée pour ce qui s'est
passé dans notre pays moment nous
parlons
la dgs si nos services de renseignement
territoriaux procède à des levées de
doute procèdent à des arrestations
bâtissent des procédures sur la base des
informations qu'il dispose avec tous les
services de renseignement dit du premier
cercle du second cercle et les unités de
coordination que sont lus clac et les
modes qui permettent aujourd'hui
d'assurer la cohérence de tout le
dispositif
ce dont ont besoin nos services de
renseignements et de lutte
antiterroriste c'est de stabilité c'est
une liaison qui souhaitent une liaison
absolument essentiel entre le travail de
coordination qui est fait par le niveau
et je pense en particulier à la dgs et
la dgse et le renseignement
territoriales qui avait malheureusement
était bien trop je ne m'appesantis pas
mes mises à mal par la suppression de la
direction centrale des renseignements
généraux que vous aviez ordonné en 2008
et qui faisait qu'il nous manquait un
élément particulier dans notre
dispositif
donc ce dont nous avons besoin c'est de
cette cohésion de cette cohérence entre
le terrain et les signaux forts que nous
pouvons détecter
pour cela il n'y a pas besoin d'une
réorganisation avec une agence qui ne
correspondent pas notre modèle mais a
donné des moyens et ça c'est
incompatible les moyens